羽根じゃあ図説をねっ
[音楽]
ん
深い意味はありません的で皆さんホイッスル使ったことあると思うんですよ
授業の体育とかでも使ってもなるしああそれぐらいしかないですけどホイッスル
p って誰なんですか増えずえあれの一番でかい音が出る増えて何がなってこられたん
ですけどもこちらでした
ストーンワールズなんとかなとは s とってください条件なんですよねと0
これが一応今あるホイッスル笛の中で一番て外音がでるそうやで増えらしいみたいなん
でしょこれならそれはか何かでしょうかもう名前か恋じゃねストームちょっと英語解除
しますマーブラー z
ホイッスルはなぁ世界でちまう政府って書いてある方がすごい
水の中区分線ってちょっとヤバいけどなんかこれネットで住みたいです
けどもう願い音出すんじゃないかコツがいるらしいんですよねやまこれはアメリカの
なんか米軍で使われてるらしいですよこれ
a アメリカの米軍これ使ってるんだって書いてある&んやり線とサーメます
すいーという岩盤シティプレスええええウソでしょこれアメリカの警官の3人に1人は
これ持ってるなんてで過ごすスイッチみたいじゃんまあでもやっぱすごいやっぱ人を
気づかせるっていう面でめちゃくちゃ音がうるさくて有効らしいですねえ
ちょっと開けてみましょううわっえっ写真来るほんとなんの変哲もない普通の
ホイッスルですけどこれ本当に住んでうるさいですよな金なんかネットで調べたらだ
から出すのにすごいコツれるって書いてありますよね
me
3 way ああああ
ません
あああっっっ
頑張ってやばいこれどうやって俺使うんだこれ
自分で拭けないんだよ
まあなんかやっぱこれやばやばいやばいやばいん
[音楽]
やっぱって本当に丼ああわあ
やばい1回で作ってみよっ
うん
me
ん
nao
口蹄疫んじゃあの普通に寿司食った飲んでいきたいと思っ
ん
i am
[音楽]
そうやわけないやまあ叫び声みたいなじゃあねます
シーッ
ん
me
やばいよそれマジでこれが世界で一番歌いこいつ良いシーズン
一番渡しちゃいけないいやーこれほんとにすごいですあの
やないこれ使ってたらマジでどんな女てる人での束を起こせると思いますこれどうなん
かどうやって伝えればいいのか見てる人になんかねえパソコンとスマホで見てる方音量
の限界があると思うんですけどちょっと見てゼロ距離で本気で弾いてみ
ますね聞いてください
これをつくって不愉快さ俺はこんなに史上最強なくて包囲するなんですけど名鑑雇えば
皆さんこれご存知でしょうか
ワイングラス大きな音で割るって言うのを聞いたことあるしてみませんですよあと
なんかああ
あー音の葉となんかえっ
バグったね夫の八丁というんですからわかんないんだのうまいことをとって振動なん
ですよ振動板いいことかて伝えればその中で一角に発音があってヴァリンって追われ
るっていう見たことあると思うんですけどもそんなんだあのストーブ使えばワンパンな
んじゃないかっていうなんたらもう何でも叩いてくるところがある
sa 後は取り皿漂ったことは理想の木が雪に帰ってみましょう
13年気がしますけど
無理か劣化所前としています
[音楽]
6日ん
はあああ
[音楽]
あああああっはぁああああ
なんか今のか調べた人は中にストローいい音振動してるとストラー震えるんですよね
ああ
はあああ
わー
やっぱ youtube 言ってるあるいはこれよああ
うっいやー声じゃなくて抜きはストーブでるんです
ストールでフルーレんだがそもそもいきます
うんかざること山の如し
来るために7こんなこともあろうかと
うまく準備いたしましたもうねここまで来ると何か大人は何が暴力なんですよねからに
波長とかそういうのが1点などで音が増えるのお腹合わせるとかじゃなくても音の
フォールハイパーボイスだってなんかライブなどをすごい言えるじゃんですか地面買っ
てるっていう読みたいなこれだけの威力があるとすれば nikko 使えば狙いなん
ですよたら女これに後でつけるかどうかなきゃいきます
ああああああ
あーこれなら犯罪いきますよいませんふぅ
プー1
voodoo
スリッパお前こんなこともあろうかと
3つ目有馬2つではれなかったらもう3つで行くしかないでしょもうそこらへんの
ライブ会場に競ってデカイ音が鳴ると思うので確実にばれるんですよ
実は6ですねと指で助っ人を呼びます
とりあえず全力で音を出してこれを破りたいって本当に入ってるわけですね
封印の杖
これ一人だところです一個のほうがいいんじゃないんですよ一個やってみてください
です
[音楽]
逃げてる気がすんだよなぁ暗い星の危機
生徒や3人でやります三つで z旗波の音が出てると思うんでさすがに言われると思い
ます
て全力でここに貼ってあれば割れて絶対ブックを振動てるぞ
意外です
ステーの
[音楽]
ん
ああああああ
そしてもちょっといるからここでも実際はいうテレビはいる
もう一息ですね
セガにうるさすぎて音が響かない地下にきましたさせずにも出かけず近所で離れる
広がったのでずギア者4人でやっていると思います
どれだけ使っていることなんです
ございますいきましょうばいばーい恋がふわり
杯以来計6
[音楽]
ブーバーし